i took the test now
and it's a positive pregnancy
ah so these rumors might be true there's
been some online speculation
that yara and jovi welcomed a baby girl
into the world
last year and from the looks of it this
is the moment when she found out she was
pregnant i want to do something and
watch now imagine we'll have a baby i
will need to sit at home
especially when enjoyable goes to work
which i will do alone with a kid i mean
that's not my plan for sure well now her
plan is to tell jovi
once he gets back from work and based
off of the glimpse we got of his
reaction
i'm honestly confused i don't know if
this baby news is official
or not this one's a half a line so you
are lying to me
we'll get to that in just a few plus
we have to talk about stephanie who
finally made
it to belize to see her 27 year old boo
ryan the 52 year old went
bearing multiple gifts including the
ring
she wants ryan to propose to her with
if you and i decide that we could make
things work
that would be the ring that i would want
you to propose
with stephanie girl you are making it
too
easy hey 90 day fans fam
it's melisia before we get into
stephanie and ryan's
unique situation let's chat about
yara jovi and the baby news after
yara took the pregnancy test and it came
back positive
she called her friend in ukraine who
seemed just as disappointed as she was
i can't understand yet i think i can't
understand that i'm pregnant no
that's not with me yara revealed that
after her miscarriage
her doctor told her that it would be
hard to get pregnant again
so it makes sense to why she's so
surprised
at the same time i think this is a good
thing
i understand that she just moved to a
new country and things are complicated
between her
and jovi but she is getting
what a lot of women who've been in her
position dream of
which is a second chance at motherhood
yeah i know i just got really heavy
there
but it's true it's also a bit ironic
that right before jovi went off to work
he brought up the idea of starting a
family
and yara told him that she wasn't ready
now
he's on his way back four weeks later
and it looks like baby number one is on
the way
yeah you know based off of that
conversation they had at dinner
i assumed that jovi would be super
excited to hear this news but i was
wrong
because in the teaser for next week this
man
looks shocked and i'm not talking about
shocked in a happy-go-lucky way
i have to tell you something if i'm
pregnant
what you're happy it's hard for me to
believe that all of a sudden she gets to
america and she's pregnant so
fast this one's a half a line so you are
lying to me
in true 90-day fashion the t's left us
not knowing
what to think maybe she read the test
wrong
or maybe she didn't and jovi is just
being
jovi either way hopefully we get a clear
answer
next week let's move on to stephanie
and ryan after being ignored by him
for days at a time and constantly
arguing over the phone
stephanie reunited with ryan in his home
country of belize
after being apart for almost a year
[Music]
[Music]
okay so that's the moment i've been
waiting for
all season when it comes to their
storyline
i wanted to see with my own eyes how
they interact
in person because i was starting to
believe
that stephanie was making this love
situation up in her head
now i see that she's not and ryan
is fully playing into this relationship
even though it's so
obvious that he just wants to get to
america
i mean he said it himself some days
definitely she drives me really crazy
you know like
i would probably just want to give up on
all this you know but i'm hoping that
she's willing to work
with me and right here right now let's
make a new beginning a new chapter fresh
because i'm actually way too deep in it
already and i actually really want to
get to america and i want to see what
america looks like you know
yeah we know what's interesting
is i don't even think stephanie would
have a problem hearing him say
something like that she revealed that
she loves to give him
nice things since he didn't have a lot
growing up
so maybe to her america would just be
another gift
who knows well speaking of gifts
once they made it to the resort
stephanie popped open her suitcase
full of items for ryan she bought him
sneakers slides a few pair of shades
some boxer briefs because he said he was
low on them
she also threw in some outfits and a
couple of
watches one that cost three thousand
dollars
i know you lose a lot of things please i
don't want you to lose that one this
if i lose this i'll probably go hide in
a hole from you
yeah right okay there we have a deal all
right
over the past few years i've spent
thousands on his gifts
my question is how do you know if
someone genuinely likes you
or wants to be around you if you're just
constantly giving them something
how can you tell if they're really there
for you
you can't and that's the issue here
you know what stephanie should do she
shouldn't give
ryan a dime or any gifts
for at least two months and see if he
sticks around
just try it there is a part of me that
feels like she knows he would leave
if she stops and that's why she keeps
spending that money
and to make matters worse she knows that
ryan is not faithful to her in their
relationship
after they sorted through his gifts she
asked to go through his phone
she didn't find anything but deep down
she knew he got rid of all the evidence
before she arrived
who's kayla sc
um yeah that's my cousin kayla
from my dad's side ryan knows how to
keep his sugar mama
okay fast forward to that night the two
are at dinner
and stephanie she is looking good in her
pink tassel dress
they started to talk about ryan coming
to america
and the struggles that they've been
facing with the k1 visa
due to the coronavirus it's stress not
knowing thinking you were coming and
then
you know now we don't know when you can
come
you know i'm gonna get to the states you
know that right
i mean i will we will get approved and
everything will go true
so stick with me okay i don't care how
many obstacles you think is in a way on
how many times you turn me down you know
i'll get to the stage
just remember that there's the ryan
there's the person that i fell in love
with
and i filed a k1 visa for
love is truly blind
he didn't say anything about building a
life with her
all i heard is that he wants to get to
the states let's remember that
we'll remember well after that
it didn't take long for stephanie to
pull out the ring
she wants him to propose to her with
she's doing all the heavy lifting at
this point this is the ring that my
mother
got from my father if you and i
decide that we could make things work
that would be the ring that i would want
you
to propose with
[Music]
you're holding the ring now okay so it's
in your hands
the one part is trying to get you to
trust and love me like you first did
before i know you're still
in love with me and you still love me of
course yes but i need to prove some
stuff for you
i'm a change man and i want better for
my life and i want better for us you
know
and then i'll pop the questions boom you
know
we've seen the cougar scenario play out
on 90 day fiance before but i don't
think
we've ever seen anything quite like this
if you thought things were wild already
it's about to take a drastic turn
because stephanie
is still holding in this huge
secret it's really exciting to finally
hear him talk about
a plan to propose but you know i still
haven't been totally honest with him
about
sleeping with his cousin harris so i'm
feeling guilty
only on 90 day fiance only on 90 day
fiance i am speechless
let's go ahead and take a look at how
she plans to tell him
next week you want to know the truth
draft right
threw you out of the hotel i met your
cousin harris manny
well you know
i wouldn't be surprised if he already
knows
the way men talk sometimes his cousin
might have already told him
this is a lot alright 90 day fans film
to stay updated on all the latest news
coming out of the 90 day universe
make sure you stick with e.t because we
are covering it all
i'll see you next time
you